Handedness is a universal human trait.
Some people prefer the left hand, some the
right, and some are ambidextrous, and can
use both.
But what about your dog… can it be… left
pawed?
Hey left-handed mice users, I'm Jules here
for DNews.
Humans handedness is influenced by hundreds
of genes and environmental factors.
That being said, a consistent 10 percent of
the human population is left-hand dominant…
so there's definitely a big genetic component.
A study in PLOS Genetics identified a gene,
PCSK6, which helps determine how the body
organizes itself in early development, and
correlated it with hand-dominance.
But, if handedness is genetic, shouldn't we
see it throughout the rest of the natural
world too?
Well, it is seen in some animals!
Great apes have handedness, for example; it
has been detailed in studies published in
Behavioural Brain Research and Animal Cognition.
Scientists have theorized one of the influencing
factors of hand dominance is rooted in the
language processing part of the brain, but
it could also have been passed down by our
ancestors, thanks to our use of tools.
The studies on great apes found they used
different hands for different activities!
They preferred their right-hand for inanimate
targets like sticks or toys, but for grooming
they didn't report any dominance at all!
Researchers believe this may be due to which
hemisphere of the brain is being used.
Grooming is emotional and social, while grabbing
sticks is purely functional.
This functional preference for hands has been
observed in other primates too!
Seventy percent of chimps are right-handed
for functional tasks like manipulating a tool,
or hilariously, which hand they choose when
they throw feces at the researchers…
MRI scans again showed it was probably due
to brain hemispheres!
Evolutionarily, scientists believe this preference
for one hand may have appeared even before
chimps and humans split from their common
ancestor, as the scans showed similar structures
to our own brains.
Some enterprising researchers found similar
brain structures toward handedness exist in
cats, but with a twist: they're sex specific!
When cats went to play with toys or remove
food from jars, they found females preferred
to use their right-paw, while males went left!
Cat brains have this weird specialization
too!
Dogs on the other paw, don't seem to have
this brain specialization.
A 2006 study in Behavioural Processes found
no population-level preference for a dominant
"hand," but that it might just be split 50-50.
Scientists haven't just studied our fur-babies
though.
Kangaroos were discovered to be hand-specific
(weirdly, most of them are lefties), and frogs
were found prefer their right foot for some
tasks.
Fish prefer one eye to the other when spotting
predators!
And even some birds, like chickens and pigeons,
have brain-level hemisphere specializations
for some visual tasks.
But overall, quadruped animals aren't often
studied for handedness -- one because they
don't have hands, but two, because they're
usually walking on all of their limbs.
That’s obviously a weird thing to think
about, but handedness is kind of weird anyway.
Even though we've identified some genes involved,
geneticists don’t agree on the exact process
of how it happens.
So we don’t really know where it comes from!
It just… is!
And overall, as usual... more research is
needed.
I love that.
We can’t do episodes like this without our
sponsors.
If you listen to music and podcasts and are
looking for a new Bluetooth speaker, check
out Monster’s reimagined boombox, the Monster
Blaster.
It’s available for monthly payments starting
at $25.
The Monster Blaster has the power to bring
music to life indoors and out.
Check it out at themonsterblaster.com/dnews.
To blow your mind even further, animals aren't
the only things scientists have found to have
left or right "handedness..." molecules and
chemicals can be handed too.
Find out why, here!
And what about your pet?
Do they have a preferred paw or claw or flipper?
Let us know down below in the comments and
don't forget to like and subscribe to DNews
for more episodes every day.